It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for waking up and joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Moco-chan, do you know what episode it is today?
Today!
It's...
Episode 175!
BAU BAU!
Do we need confetti for today?
Yeah, I want a confetti.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, all of you!
Why not confetti?
I bought a confetti.
Huh?
Why not confetti?
I guess if you bought it, you could have confetti, Moco-chan, but... Let's make sure we have...
Confetti everyday if we want it, okay?
Okay.
Well, for those who are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays.
Today, it's Monday.
Now, so that we can get more balance in our lives!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
One!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Yay!
A new week!
A new week has started!
A new day has started!
A new month started a little while ago, Moco-chan.
We can still be sad about it!
Do we need to be sad about it?
Let's look at it positively, Moco-chan.
I'm gonna be sad.
It's already October!
Just like that, Ruffians!
It's already September!
No, it's Monday.
Oh!
It's Monday!
The months are in the double digits!
The months are in the double digits now, Moco-chan.
That means we're just one step closer to a brand new year!
Spooky.
BAU BAU!
BAU
You want the information right, Ruffians?
That is true.
We have to think of it logically.
Not emotionally.
I know.
You can get a bit emotional when it comes to Pero sightings, right?
Moco-chan, where was Pero spotted this time?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
You donut!
Pero ended up eating one of those donuts there and tried to pull a fast one on you, huh?
Huh?
Think he's smart, huh?
No.
Did he think he could get access to your fridge of yummies and a pudding this way, maybe?
A pudding?
He's put himself in a dangerous situation now.
That's true.
Ruffians!
How many of you would take a bite out of this donut, huh?
Huh?
Don't mind if you do!
Gotta throw away all the donuts now?
Pero daishiku!
You make my mistake!
Donuts are usually boneless.
Can you imagine a bone-in donut?
I don't know if you trust it.
Oh, there's a lot less Ruffians than maybe I thought.
Let's try this.
Wait.
We have to get the official.
Official information.
Okay.
You don't want to imagine that.
I mean, it's not looking bad, right?
Right?
I feel like Ruffians, you could take a bite out of this and it'd be okay.
No?
There you go.
Official.
Eat or no?
Yes or no?
Well... I don't know about this.
You could have this one.
I'm gonna skip it.
FUWAMOCO, we have the other ones, right?
There's three of them.
There's only two of us, so you know.
You could have one.
Two each, you know?
Or two together.
And then you still have one and then an awful one.
Pero- Pero- No, I think Pero would taste like a donut here.
Well, let's see.
You would eat him!
Okay, Ruffians.
Go ahead, you can have a Pero donut.
We'll have the other one.
Yeah.
You- You can have that one.
And I guess the extra one too.
Just a nice week started off by sharing Pero donuts, that's all.
Interesting.
I don't know, Ruffians!
Maybe, maybe it's a good idea to throw the Pero looking one out the window.
Spoiled food goes out.
Yeah, or you could throw it into the garbage disposal.
That's the sound you would make if you threw it in the garbage disposal.
BAU BAU!
Compost bin for Pero.
A nice way to make sure everything gets reused.
Garbage disposal.
BAU BAU!
October!
There's a lot of exciting things going on.
hololive English Promise!
They're having their second anniversary!
They're having a 3D live!
It's gonna be happening in just a few days on the 8th at 7pm PT.
But look!
Look at this cute visual here!
What outfits!
So cool!
I did notice one thing though.
What?
Did you see Beisampoi's tail?
Oh yeah.
She has a piercing through it.
A piercing?
What's the word?
A clothespin.
That's not clothing, that's her tail!
Clothespin through the tail!
Ouch.
A safety pin.
Don't think about it.
It's okay.
Well, she looks really cool though, so that's what matters, right?
Forget the pain.
Yes!
Look at Kronii-senpai here too!
I like her sleeves.
Why?
I'm in the way.
I'm in the way, huh?
I like IRyS-senpai's braids!
That's so cute!
They're like cyberpunk even feeling.
Maybe?
I think so.
Wait, so Bae-senpai has her dice.
Coney-senpai has a pocket watch.
Iren-senpai?
She has a necklace.
She has a necklace, but everyone has a necklace.
Maybe that will get explained when she has one.
Maybe?
Rings and crowns?
She has all the toys.
I know based on this cute visual, I wonder what kind of live it's gonna be.
This will be a very cool performance though, so let's look forward to it!
At 7pm PT, I wish them a big happy 2nd anniversary by calendars while you still can!
BAU BAU!
Oh YouTube!
That's where the anniversary live is happening, yeah?
YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Exciting.
And Ruffians, well there's also some more news.
I wish we didn't have to share these kind of news but it was announced the other day that Hiyodoshi Ao of hololive device week was that she would be graduating from hololive.
Ao-kun, she had been on hiatus for illness and we know that she was looking forward to returning soon.
So we were really really surprised when we heard that she'd be graduating.
We are really looking forward to our return, right?
Yeah.
Being able to see all of Riko's solo performance live again!
Yeah, I'll miss her.
FUWAMOCO!
We didn't really get to talk with Ao-kun as much as we wanted to.
But what we did, you know, we had lots of fun!
Yeah, we had lots of fun!
You know, we had HologTA!
And, you know, we ran into Ao-kun at the studio.
We got to talk a bit at the studio.
A little bit.
Oh yeah, we had fun in the VR chat for, you know, Justice is Halloween.
Getting all those head pats too!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
We know we girls are gonna be having a big big performance, in-person performance at Ariake coming up in December.
Yeah!
So wishing the four of them the best!
We can't wait to see what kind of amazing, emotional live it's gonna be, so... Yeah.
It will be amazing!
But she'll be very very missed, so... She's the coolest and the funniest.
Very much so.
Open your Ikemen.
BAU BAU!
Pick your icon!
But!
Ruffians, there was some more news that all of us were surprised about.
There was updates!
There was updates and the updates came all of a sudden.
All of a sudden and we were like what?
Ruffians, take a look at this!
This is FUWAMOCO!
I'm Nandou!
It's my color now!
Look!
BAU BAU!
They're so cute!
BAU BAU have all their pictures themselves though!
Right!
All the poses they can make!
They're so cute!
But at first, we were surprised because we're like, look!
Asahi and Nandroid is coming out!
It's so cute!
And then we're like,
Wait, wait, what's next to sighting?
Oh!
It's FUWAMOCO!
That's us!
Oh, finally, when's the release date?
We don't know, we'll have to see!
That's what I'm sure you're curious about and something we're curious about too!
We will find out maybe sometime in the future and I'm sure it'll be just as surprising as the color versions here are too!
Look at me!
BAU BAU!
Yes, it's a big hey hey!
And Mococo!
Yes!
I can't really see them, but our tails... You'll have to get a better look later, huh?
Are you gonna buy these for Mama Puppy?
Of course!
Mama Puppy loves all the merchandise that we send to her too.
You're not going to touch the tails, okay?
No.
I'll tell you, okay, Ruffians?
If you touch the tail, you know what's gonna happen?
It's gonna feel like plastic.
It's the truth.
It's not gonna feel fluffy.
It's not gonna feel fuzzy, okay?
It's gonna feel like plastic.
Why was I even bothered?
Why was I looking forward to this?
That's gonna happen.
Bye!
We're so happy!
Who knows when the next updates will come out, but let's look forward to it!
Wish it'll be surprising.
I mean, you know, surprises are good surprises, right?
BAU BAU!
What was that, Moco-chan?
It ended already, but yesterday it was Fubuki-senpai's birthday!
BAU BAU!
And as a part of the celebrations, there is also Fubuki-senpai had a sweetie Halloween night live!
Yes!
Birthday live!
But not just that!
FUWAMOCO!
We are invited too!
BAU BAU!
You can see it in the key visual here.
Just kind of behind Fubuki-senpai's ear causing mischief.
Whispering things into it.
Fubuki-senpai's live was amazing.
A lot of storybook style stuff and everything.
But together with her we performed a song called Kyousho Trickstar by All Star Project.
It's super cute!
It was a lot of fun to be able to perform and sing and dance with FUWAMOCO.
The song is really tricky.
It's really tricky.
There's the rhythm.
I don't think you probably noticed, but the rhythm changes.
It changes.
And then... It's a lot of mouthful.
And there's some interesting English parts too.
Did you notice the interesting English parts?
I like my solo.
Yeah.
Don't stab you!
I might stab you, Ruffian!
Give me a cherry pie!
Soretomo I choke you up?
Give me a void?
Soretomo I stab you to death?
BAU BAU!
Yeah, just normal stuff.
And it's a very happy, cute, fun song.
We really like the choreography too.
We get to dance with Fubuki-senpai.
I like the part where we go up and down.
And then pulling Fubuki-senpai back, forth and back.
Perfectly normal song.
But we also, we also caught up.
In the recent year, another song of Fubuki-senpai's Hoshizora e to Tsuzuku Sakamichi.
We did a little bit of narration at the beginning for that too.
I was really happy.
So if you haven't, please go check it out.
You can check out Fubuki-senpai's 3D live on her channel.
She also just released a brand new original song too.
So please go listen to that.
The MV is to come out soon.
Happy Birthday Fubuki Senpai!
Thank you!
You watch it!
Go go go go!
A little bit of a happy announcement.
Announcement?
Announcement was update.
Update.
Too bad.
Information.
I know we talked about it but it was a super chat meeting.
We mentioned it earlier.
I can't remember.
But, FUWAMOCO!
I got to do something fun!
We went to see a Takarazuka musical!
BAU BAU!
We went to the Takarazuka movie!
Takarazuka kagekidan!
Have you heard of the BAU BAU Ruffians?
Takarazuka!
Wow!
Right!
They had a Castlevania!
It's not really a stage play, it's a stage play, but it's also a musical.
Only in passing!
You've only heard of stage plays!
So Takarazuka!
Takarazuka originated in Kansai, but it's not in Tokyo.
Takarazuka is an all-female troupe singing and dancing with costumes!
Gorgeous!
Majestic!
Amazing!
Shiny!
So many lights!
Feathers!
It had an orchestra, live orchestra playing.
It's sort of similar in... It's not similar, but sort of similar in the sense that, you know, Kabuki is all male.
Yeah.
But Takarazuka is also really old.
It's been over a hundred years old.
I think it's the 111th anniversary.
Yeah, that's the sign that's behind Fuwawa there.
111.
It's so hard to believe.
It's amazing.
But then you went to go see Castlevania, right?
And then you know there's like
Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Hi.
But I feel like Takarazuka isn't very well-known over here, so I'd like it to be more well-known.
I thought, you know, it would be really nice.
I'm sure Elizabeth and Nerissa would really, really enjoy it.
It's so beautiful and a very special and important part of Japanese culture history.
So maybe check it out one day if you can.
And then after, because it was half Castlevania and then half Reveal.
And so we saw the Reveal and it was so cute and so pretty.
There's one part where they did the cam-cam.
Yeah, there's Bonnie's.
Yeah, Bonnie's was really cute.
But I think you know they've been doing more game adaptations recently too.
Ah, I saw it on private!
So maybe, maybe they'll be doing a game that you'll be proud of in the future too.
Please check it out, Ruffians, if you're curious!
It was fun!
I really want to go!
BAU BAU!
What was that?
Were you thinking about the next day's show?
I was.
Because all of you!
All of you!
I had... I had a dream!
A dream.
I had how many dreams recently?
But you have one!
I do.
I have this dream with Moco-chan!
I don't know what it is!
She said, FUWAMOCO Morning, let's talk about my dream.
I said, okay.
So, Ruffians!
I had a dream Moco-chan was there.
Ruffians, you were there too!
For some reason, Moco-chan, you decided to buy me a present.
Oh, that's nice of me!
Alright!
And, like, you got me... Oh, I remember there's zombies over there.
What?
I just remembered that part.
But let's forget the zombies for now.
Forget the zombies for now?
That was the previous part of the dream.
This is the happier part of the dream.
They were dealt with.
I don't know how.
But, Abyss, Moco-chan, you got me a special present.
Nerissa, what are you dreaming about?
Are there zombies in your dreams?
Cue it!
But, Moco-chan gave me a box.
It was like a, a wooden, like a Japanese wooden style box.
An old one.
A traditional one.
Yeah, it wasn't very like, fancy or anything.
Maybe something between Silent Hill F. Maybe that's why.
But, it was really special.
Moco-chan, you had one too.
You're like, I found matching ones!
So cute!
So that we can open them together.
Nice!
Because, they were really special.
It had some of the very first Pokemon cards inside of it.
In traditional Japanese boxes.
That's how special they are.
Inside the box I think there was like decks or something?
I don't know.
Decks?
Okay, well, 38 cards is okay.
So the Ruffians and cabbage, you all look together.
And I got really excited to kind of open some of the sleeves and I could see that some of them were already in, like, you know, the hard sleeves to protect them.
So that's kind of weird now that I think about it.
But it's okay because they're holographic.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Have a howl of a day!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Wait, did the zombies show up?
The zombies showed up in the previous part of the dream.
That's it?
I can't really remember.
I think I beat them together with Moco-chan.
I feel like somebody else was there.
Maybe it was Nerissa or Elizabeth?
That was rooms.
Rooms?
That's all I can remember.
That's the dream!
Yeah.
Yeah, that was the prior part.
I don't... How do they connect?
The zombies went away and we opened carts.
That's how it could explode.
And then Nerissa and or Elizabeth, was it goodbye?
I don't want to open carts.
They disappeared along with the zombies.
I don't know what that means.
Did you mean that one?
I don't know, maybe they didn't mean it.
What?
Okay, makes sense.
That was my GMO feelings.
I like the printer paper.
Printer paper coins are very valuable, guys.
But Ruffians, you were so like... And that's how you knew they were good, because the Ruffians were excited, right?
Yeah, I was happy.
BAU BAU!
You know, just a normal dream.
It wasn't a very colorful dream, though.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I'm an amateur at it, I don't know how to do it.
I was dropping them everywhere!
You were dropping them?!
But it's okay because the moment I opened up the cards, like the card pack, they were already in sleeves.
So it was okay.
What about the corners?
No, they were in the sleeves.
They had like the hard case on them, so it was okay.
It's okay, they had the protectors, it's okay.
Some of them did, some of them didn't.
The ones that matter did, so it's okay.
BAU BAU!
That was my dream.
Yeah.
Is it a typical Fuwawa dream, Moco-chan?
No.
I feel like usually it's more detailed.
Everything's a little bit fuzzy though, so... Not the weirdest dream.
It's still a Fuwawa dream, but not that weird, maybe.
Yeah.
I didn't tell you about the temperature or the feelings though.
No.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
Are you excited for this upcoming week?
Looking forward to having maybe some interesting dreams too!
Or maybe you're gonna take your dreams and make them reality!
Huh?
Are you ready?
Yeah!
Well, Moco-chan, maybe you... If you're ready, then I don't need a pup talk.
I think the Ruffians would like some more encouragement.
I can really make the dream come true then.
Yeah!
Okay, wow!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
It's October!
Did you know?
Did you realize?
September was here, and then,
It's gone!
It's the next blink of an eye!
And before we know it, it'll be 2026!
If you think of it that way, you know.
Isn't it a good time to get a head start on your New Year's resolutions?
Think about what matters to you in the big picture.
You know, the long one.
Are you setting yourself up for happiness?
In the end of the day, rather than success or popularity or anything, a healthy, happy life is number one, okay?
So, let's focus on aiming for that and get a head start on 2026!
Yeah!
We'll be here to support you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Ganbatte ne!
It's a good time to get a head start.
Let's do it again!
Doggy of a day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Pigi!
Awesome!
Look at those eyes!
So cute ribbon!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Pigi is a sweetheart with lots of energy.
Definitely a proportionate head and body, right Moco-chan?
Definitely.
Yeah.
So don't listen to mom being silly, okay?
Don't think about it.
Yeah, but um... Pekito, I think she'd maybe appreciate it if you try and take a photo that shows...
How proportionate everything is, right?
Yeah, proportion, yeah.
And then that way!
Mom can't make any jokes, you know.
Yeah.
Right.
This dog looks like the FUWAMOCO Nendoroid.
Hi!
Don't tell Pigi that.
Nendoroids have a pretty big head.
Moco-chan, can I do the party?
They're fine.
BAU BAU!
You're cute!
And next we have... Today I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Is this Silent Hill F?
Moco-chan.
A night walk.
You wanted to go look at the stars.
Very spooky though.
You're not supposed to go stargazing when there's no moon.
Did you know that, Moco-chan?
No.
Anytime is a good time to go out.
That's true, but maybe not for stargazing.
Is it because it's scary?
I think you need the moon to see the stars.
No.
Is that how it works?
If you look really hard, they're there.
BAU BAU!
Just a little bit.
It's beautiful, but... slightly spooky.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Have anyone ever mistaken Fuwawa as Mococo or vice versa since you arrived in Japan?
Besides the clip where Kiara mistook Mococo as Fuwawa.
Well, we can say with confidence
Other than that, no.
No, surprisingly, none.
In style of sound, they're always super duper respectful and nice.
I've actually really never ever had anything like that happen.
Stuff like a piece of paper that says FUWAWA being handed to Mococo, but I think that's just normal.
Oh, that's just being like, you know, oh I made a mistake, fine.
Yeah.
That's about it.
But, you know, if there was a staff member that did make that mistake, we wouldn't say anything.
No.
Yeah, we wouldn't want to embarrass them.
I feel like you'd be really sad.
But, you know... How... How... You know... Only Kiara-senpai.
Only Kiara-senpai.
She's the only one.
It's okay, you know, we can... We can, you know, joke with ourselves.
But you know, I sure this is because Moco-chan made it very clear that I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
And I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
And so it's all thanks to our hard work, Moco-chan.
Up until now, yes.
It's just KyoAi-senpai.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Please remember to send your doggy of the days your questions!
Pero Sightings.
And your works to us with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Very, very important FUWAMOCO Morning.
We couldn't do this without you, Ruffians.
So please share it.
BAU BAU!
We're gonna be continuing to play FUWAMOCO!
It just started!
Yeah, Moco-chan, you're playing as the first player of Mario, and I'm playing as two player.
I'm the co-star.
Yeah, I think our team together is very strong.
Very strong.
We've been having a lot of fun, though.
Yeah, the de-sync.
De-sync here, but not in Mario Galaxy.
Yeah.
We will be playing it tomorrow at 6pm PT, so we hope that you'll join us for some more super fun Mario Galaxy times and cozy story time too.
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archives, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU NENDOROID!
Thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special roleplayers today!
Justin!
BAU BAU!
Atomic Panda!
Mii!
BAU BAU!
Door!
Keycord!
BAU BAU!
It's time!
In here!
BAU BAU!
Casey!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!